le trio qui cartonnait en france d'abord
celle et oublie free c'est en 96 to be
free filip nikolic adel et franck bien
entendu on va revoir pour le plaisir une
petite compil de leur tube ça fait du
bien
[Musique]
ou pas
elle reconnaît l'étude
[Musique]
ce
[Applaudissements]
c'était un truc de ouf non mais
franchement comment on fait parce que je
voudrais dire quand on fait franck pour
c'était un succès énorme comment on fait
pour passer d'un succès incroyable des
beatles c'était les binômes et c'est sa
mort non non non non c'est pourquoi
passer une vie normale après ce qu'on
pète pas un art mais en fait l'avantagé
qu'on avait c'est que nous contrairement
à d'autres groupes on était des potes
d'enfance donc dû quoi c'est ça c'est
pour rester soudés grâce à ça ouais nous
éviter un peu de péter les plombs entre
guillemets et puis dont vivent et notre
aventure enfin on était des potes
d'enfance qui vivait un conte de fées
mais c'est vrai que si besoin c'est
juste ou parce que vous vous étiez le
seul groupe qui n'a pas été montée vous
étiez 3 potes
oui oui vous êtes dit on va pas de
karité nous avons été repéré la suite un
concours de ces appels futur top model
sur tf1 présenté par bon bref voilà on
est repéré par chorégraphe qui nous a
dit vous avez une bonne énergie
allez avoir une maison disque qui
cherche à monter un groupe à la façon de
new kids on the block et on partait oui
vous avez énormément de fans de groupe i
alors justement
ouais c'est quoi le truc le plus fou
qu'un fan effet brou une fan on a aussi
des cartes de crédit non oui c'est sûr
que c'est pas moi c'est ça caché dans un
placard une fois parce que sa mère
travaille dans l'hôtel ah ouais du coup
on rentre dans le jeu rentre dans ma
chambre et ouais c'est arrivé au point
de s'appeler isabelle alors regardez
justement parle des fans
regardez cette vidéo un concert des to
be free regardez c'est impressionnant
guérilla
[Applaudissements]
j'étais très fan de vous je crois que je
te l'aï déjà dit en fait j'avais des
posters trois posters donc dans ma
chambre de vous trois en taille réelle
et le soir avant d'aller dormir je vous
faisais un bisou sur la bouche à chacun
ses mondiaux au terme d'un match on a
tellement je vous kiffe et je vous
étaient les trois ans mezouza
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors feeling il ya eu un drame non mais
un drame
en 2009 le drame qui nous a tous marqués
c'est évidemment le décès de philippe
septembre 2009 on va rire tronc de
retrouver le jt qui ont parlé regarder
il incarnait le boys band à la française
filip nikolic est mort cette nuit à
l'âge de 35 ans il avait été le leader
des to be free à la fin des années 90
avant de se lancer dans une carrière
d'acteur nous retrouver régulièrement
sur tf1 aux côtés de roger hanin dans la
série navarro
son avocat a évoqué un abus de
somnifères c'était votre pote d'enfance
ouais ça ça quand quand vous quand vous
avez vu philippe partir qu'est ce que
vous aviez vous êtes dit peut-être ça a
été on a eu tellement de succès avant
qu'après c'est peut-être ça qui a fait
que il n'a pas pu se remettre de
l'énorme succès avant toute chose moi je
n'avais pas de contact avec philippe
pratiquement huit mois avant qu'il soit
parti d'accord j'entendais des bruits
comme quoi ça n'allait pas et puis voilà
c'est qu'il sépare des bronzés et qui
était angoissé et qui est kate c'était
un extrême sur tout ce qui faisait donc
il faisait pas les choses à moitié quand
ils étaient quelque chose voilà c'était
le coup de trop le soir aussi les
parties c'était à la fois de trop il
avait quand même il faut le dire
oser le dire il a quand même péter les
plombs un moment franchement c'est moi
je les ai connus depuis le début tu te
souviens vous veniez même chez moi et
faire des chorégraphies tout ça que
j'avais le loft dans le 9ème et j'ai
connu des débuts même avant que le
disque sorte mais un moment cette
notoriété telle cette folie lui qui a
toujours rêvé d'être une star et bon
beau gosse les trois beaux gosses et
celles ci sont rentrés dans une folie
incroyable un truc incroyable ya eu le
fric les boîtes ya tout eu
et au bout d'un moment il a un peu pété
les plombs mais ça je suis prêt dans la
pratique ce week-end
non je voulais donc simplement dire cela
c'est que effectivement il a rompu à peu
avec tout le monde
le succès n'était plus là donc ça a été
très difficile pour lui de le vivre
après même avec la série où il a réussi
à tourner sur navarro avec tf1 il y
avait plus de projets derrière c'était
assez compliqué entre temps il a eu un
enfant et il était avec sa famille etc
c'était très lesquels étaient difficiles
pour lui d'un angoissé alors qu'ils
aient du travail ou pas c'était
quelqu'un au fur et à mesure qu'ils
kiki intérieurement qui n'allait pas de
toute façon donc que ce soit avec ou son
succès c'est quelqu'un qui n'allait pas
depuis la jeune déjà il avait un
problème d'existence j'en avais besoin
de plaire à tout le monde
la mère de benjamin avait essayé avec
roger hanin de le prendre un petit peu
en charge dans brigade navarro essayé de
le raisonner il disait il par un sucette
c'est impossible de l'aider c'est en
tout cas c'est vrai que c'était un deal
était très très bon dans tous sens
vraiment très très bon dans tout ce
qu'il faisait il ya rudy les potiches
clover moi je me rappelle des politiques
lover c'est vrai j'adorais ce groupe
vous avez vous parfois regarder on va
voir des images de la terre
[Musique]
au delà
oui
m
[Musique]
je
m
j'adore le
quand encore ma mère
[Applaudissements]
rudy comment ça se passe parce que c'est
vrai que tout le monde se demande c'est
vrai que c'était vous aussi c'est un
énorme carton les politiques l'odeur
comment ça se passe là prêt quand on
sent que ça ça voilà que vous vous étiez
préparé à ça ou pas vous êtes marrants
du tout ouais du tout du tout ça et
qu'on était des gosses qui rêvait dans
leur quartier ouais ça regardait
l'émission graines de star qu'on en a dû
tout à l'heure qui était un peu le
redire l'ancêtre du télé crochet on va
dire bien sûr et on rêvait de tout
simplement passé dans cette émission qui
on a eu l'occaz et à partir de là je
peux rien te dire ça a été trop rapide
quoi rapide pour moi ça c'est comment ça
s'est fini les politiques lover en fait
ça va reprendre mais quand on était on
était jeune donc on a fini par
s'embrouiller assez certain moment ouais
mais on avait quoi on avait une
vingtaine d'années à l'époque donc on
était des gosses donc tu mets les filles
l'oseille la notoriété la casse tadic
s'est réveillé ça ou ça le point commun
entre tous ces groupes ils sont se sont
arrêtés mais très rapidement en même
temps c'est trois quatre mois tous ça a
été horrible
ce guide étonnant crise des déchets
squats c'est un énorme aurons plus et
non hélas vrai j'étais comme un ouf sur
vous et premier boys band des escouades
merci à lui c'est le premier avec marlon
et où moi vous c'est un casting guerre
vous avez dit me voilà rappelle voyage
connaissait marlon en fait on avait fait
du mannequinat donc pour la presse jeune
je sais moi aussi j'avais tourné un peu
normal aurait fait deux trois conneries
et et est donc vous aussi c'est un
énorme carton
ouais sa vie très gros et très rapide
ouais c'est ça qui a été le plus
étonnant c'est bien ça ou pas on vous a
dit vous allez dès dimanche tu as alors
non bien évidemment personne ne s'attend
à ça vraiment mais les producteurs ils
n'ont pas senti tout de suite
non non non moi j'étais un peu préparé
parce que j'ai dans un autre boss bande
à van avant mon service militaire mais
mais du coup non on se prépare pas à
cette fulgurance et vous commencez fille
nicole l élégie squatts à s'effilocher
un espèce de truc un peu voilà
filandreux de quoi y'a même pas eu de
vraiment eu de clash des trucs non en
fait les chacun est parti de son côté de
plus en plus on s'est retrouvé à deux
finales à faire des galas on a pressé le
citron jusqu'au bout et puis voilà vous
regrettez cette époque ou pas disons
cabine espèce de candeur assez agréable
en fait que je retrouve pas aujourd'hui
même chez ces jeunes que je vois main
c'est vrai et pas une candeur naïve je
veux dire un espèce de truc bienveillant
voilà dont tout le monde se foutait à
cette époque là quand même un peu la
chair et les médias mais mais on
retrouve pas ça non mais je suis je suis
je suis assez d'accord
c'est vrai que c'est une c'est une belle
période autant innocentes on revoit sa
vie celle de l'innocence à une période
d'innocence être contente d'en appuyer
tous à tout se passe bien la vie c'est
que du bonus pour moi voilà c'est ça
c'est ça qu'on dit on dit c'est que du
bonus après la musique tu vis ton rêve
voilà c'est ça des gens ils se lèvent le
matin ils vont l usine
tu fais de la musique car thierry basset
comme berlin moitié vide ce jour est de
rien faire ici c'est incroyable la toile
francs que théo ne t'arrête pas ouais
ouais bah par cette petite période là
transitoire qui est difficile mais sinon
a vivement dans à la rentrée aurait que
tout reprenne et qu'on fasse des galas
et du théâtre et voilà que de nouvelles
d'adèle ou pas il fait quoi d'être
jouera d'adèle il habite près de la
frontière suisse si les courtiers dans
l'aviation de luxe ah ouais d'accord
avec ce qu'on avait dit exactement parce
que même si la ducasse talent dire je
viens d'en inscrire merci
c'est fait